we will send really nice photo by some
fans in Colombia in South America of a
periodic table they've made but if you
look at it carefully it's rather strange
it's much wider than it normally and it
just seems to go on for on and on
forever doesn't look like the ordinary
periodic tables that I've got here in my
office or of course the one on our
periodic videos website and the reason
why it's different is because they have
put the actinides and lanthanides the
rare earth elements and the radioactive
elements in their right place in the
periodic table I was wondering how I
could explain this to you and then I was
sent this periodic table by the website
science shirts who supplied many my ties
and it's really fun because if you look
at this periodic table it looks strange
because all the transition metals are
missing so these are the elements it's
in German I should say this periodic
table these are the elements that are
known as the main group elements so we
have the sodium Group the alkali metals
we have the alkaline earths and then we
have boron carbon oxygen and fluorine
over here but if you open it up like
this then you can see we have this group
here of the so called d-block elements
of the transition metals and this
periodic table looks much the same as
the ones on our website and roundabouts
here but and this is where it gets
really good if you pull a bit harder
everything is revealed and now we have
down here the lanthanides the rare
earths and the actinides the radioactive
elements which involve the so called F
orbitals of the
element's filling up and now you have
the whole periodic table with each
element in its right position according
to atomic number you can ask why on
earth then they all look like this and
the answer is that this is very awkward
to print if you fit it on the page
you either waste a lot of space or the
type gets very small so usually what
happens is that this group here is moved
underneath down there so you get the
shape that everybody recognizes within
these elements down here which are
boring and sometimes left off by those
who don't really understand the
excitement of the periodic table the
point about periodic table is there lots
of ways of putting it round and there's
a quite an interesting one called the
Janek periodic table which looks quite
different from any of these where
they've arranged the elements in a
different way but is really good if
you're trying to synthesize elements
because they have an extra space
relevant 119 and 120 which don't appear
on these so in the end when you show the
periodic table you're showing whatever
form you think is going to be useful for
whatever the point it is you want to
make and in Columbia where they wanted
to take a group photo with as many of
the students there as possible the long
one was much better because they could
get everybody in